but why should we study deep reinforce
learning today
well as I mentioned earlier
recent progress on data-driven
large-scale AI systems has led to some
pretty impressive results but the
methods that are trained to Simply copy
data produced by humans they're mainly
impressive because they produce things
that look like human generated results
but in many cases we actually want
algorithms that will do better than the
the typical human data either because
the human data is not good or because
it's hard to obtain or because we really
do want the highest possible performance
like in the case of alphago we want
solutions that are impressive because
the machine didn't need to be told how
to do something because it discovered it
on its own because it discovered a
solution that was better or because I
discovered a solution in a situation
where it didn't have the benefit of
human foresight to provide the kind of
training data that it needed
so recall that a lot of these very
successful data driven methods work on
the basis of density estimation
which has particular implications it
means that that these methods will
produce the kinds of data that humans
tend to produce but it also means that
they in some sense won't go beyond uh
good human behavior they might be much
better at indexing into human data as a
certainly the case with large language
models they have a lot more knowledge
but not necessarily better at utilizing
that knowledge to solve concrete
problems if you tell a large language
model for example to persuade somebody
that it's uh you know in their best
interest to go see a doctor the language
model probably won't be able to persuade
them much better than a person would
despite the fact that it has this huge
uh
repository of Internet knowledge to draw
so where does that leave us well we've
got these data-driven AI systems that
learn about the real world from data
potentially huge amounts of data but
they don't really try to do better than
the data in any meaningful sense and
we've got these reinforcement learning
systems and they can optimize a goal
with a merging behavior and that seems
like something that should address one
of the major shortcomings of these
data-driven AI methods but of course we
need to figure out how to use these
reinforced learning Methods at scale we
need to combine them with the kinds of
huge models and huge data sets that have
been so successful and that's really
where the Deep part in deep reinforced
learning comes in
so data driven AI is all about using
data reinforcement learning is all about
optimization
deep reinforced learning is about this
kind of optimization at scale and data
without optimization basically doesn't
allow us to solve new problems in New
Waves it might allow us to be very good
at indexing into large data sets to
figure out solutions that are human-like
but not necessarily solutions that are
superhuman
something that I I often like to bring
up in the context of this discussion is
an article written by Richard Sutton so
Richard Sutton is actually one of the
pioneers of reinforcement learning he
was basically the person who popularized
reinforcement learning and computer
science whereas previous to that it was
really a subject of study primarily in
psychology
so in many ways he sort of founded the
study of reinforcement learning in CS
Richard Sutton wrote an article in 2019
called The Bitter lesson
for those of you that haven't read it I
very strongly encourage you to
um to read through it it provides a very
concise and very clear explanation or
why we've seen this revolution in
data-driven AI over the last few years
and in that essay
he writes that we have to learn the
better lesson the building and how we
think we think does not work in the long
run the two methods that seem to scale
arbitrarily are learning and search what
he's arguing here is essentially that if
we want very powerful learning machines
we should build machines that are very
good at using data and very good at
being scaled up and not necessarily
worry so much about engineering these
systems so that they solve problems the
way that we think that humans solve
problems
as an example
we might imagine building a system for
detecting cars by somehow engineering
some detectors for like wheels and uh
and headlights and and things like that
and then try to program in that well a
car someone has four wheels and like two
headlights on the front and two in the
back so if you see some wheels and some
headlights well that's probably a car
and we can basically program that in and
that's actually how people used to build
computer vision systems
um maybe about a decade ago
but these days we very rarely build
perception systems that way instead what
we do is we get lots of examples of cars
labeled them as cars and let the
computer figure it out and that's
basically what Richard Sutton is saying
that let's not worry so much about
building in how we think the problem
should be solved and let's instead of
focus on scalable learning machines
the machine Learning Community has had
sort of a Perpetual debate about the
degree to which we should be building in
these kinds of components and that's why
this this article uh was so influential
but a lot of people who read this
article take away kind of a funny uh
impression Maybe
that the emphasis is really on just
scale and not really on the particular
algorithm that is being scaled up so
maybe it's okay if we just take let's
say supervised learning methods and as
long as we can figure out how to
basically Shuffle more data into gpus or
build larger server Farms that's really
all that matters data plus lots of
machines lots of computers and not not
worry about how the problem is solved
but that's not actually what the essay
says notice how it says learning and
search it doesn't say learning and gpus
it doesn't say learning in Big Data so
it says learning and search and there's
a very important reason for that
learning is about extracting patterns
from data you look at the world you pull
in some data and you train some learning
machine on that and it finds the
patterns that are in there
search is about using computation to
extract inferences Rich Sutton is using
the term search in a very particular
very technical sense that it's commonly
used in reinforcement learning search
doesn't mean like a star search
necessarily search means some kind of
computation or optimization
that you use to extract inferences so
search is not about getting more data
searches about using what you've got to
reach more uh interesting and more
meaningful conclusions
search is essentially optimal Center
some kind of optimization process that
uses typically iterative computation to
make rational decisions
and it's important to have both of those
things
because learning is what allows you to
understand the world and searches what
allows you to leverage that
understanding for interesting emergent
Behavior
and you really need both if you want to
have flexible and rational and optimal
decision making in real world settings
you need to understand how the world
works and then instead of just using
your understanding to regurgitate what
you've seen before use that
understanding to find a better solution
than what you've seen before
that's basically what deep reinforced
learning tries to do
data without optimization doesn't allow
us to solve new problems in new ways
optimization without data without
experience it's hard to apply in the
real world that side of things like
simulators where you can write down
equations of motion but if you have both
of those things then you can start to
solve real world problems in more
optimal ways
foreign
here where this view is not just about
how to control robots or how to play
video games I specifically emphasized in
the previous section that deep
reinforcement learning methods have been
applied very fruitfully to arrange our
other domains too and there's actually a
deep reason for this to try to
understand this reason let's ask a very
basic question let's ask the question
why do we need machine learning
and as an aside to help us answer that
question we can ask an even more basic
question why do we need brains
the neuroscientist Daniel walper who
knows quite a bit about brains had this
to say on this topic he said we have a
brain for one reason and one reason only
and that's to produce adaptable and
complex movements movement is the only
way we have affecting the world around
us and I believe that to understand
movement is to understand the whole
brain now it won't surprise you to know
that Daniel walpert works on the
Neuroscience of motor control but I
think this quote is very
thought-provoking and I think we can
apply the same intuition to machine
learning and formulate this posture load
perhaps we need machine learning for one
reason and one reason only and that's to
produce adaptable and complex decisions
that makes a lot of sense in the same
way that your brain is only useful to
you so far as it moves your body because
that's the only way that it affects the
world around it the machine Learning
System is only useful insofar as it
makes good decisions because that's the
only thing it's outputting
and now we can start to view all machine
learning problems to this lens not as a
problems of prediction but as problems
of decision making this is obvious if
you're controlling a robot your decision
is how to move the joints it's obvious
if you're driving a car your decision is
how to steer the car but even something
like a computer vision system in the end
of the decision making system if I make
a decision which could be the image
label
but really the decision has implications
what happens Downstream of that image
label maybe this perception system is
detecting how many cars there are at an
intersection and that label will be used
to determine how to route traffic so it
has long-term implications maybe the
computer vision system is detecting
people in a security camera and it's
going to call security if it sees
someone where they shouldn't be well
that's definitely a decision that could
lead to some very complex and very
difficult to model outcomes if you view
all of the outcomes of machine learning
problems as decisions then it becomes
clearer that all of machine learning
problems are really reinforcement
problems in Disguise it's just that in
some cases we have the privilege of
supervised label data that can Aid Us in
solving
and while this perspective might be a
little bit reductionist I think it's
important to keep in mind because it
really tells us those building blocks
learning and search are not just special
things that we want for robots and video
game playing but they're really General
building blocks of AI systems
and that brings us to some big questions
like how do we build intelligent
machines very general intelligent
machines not uh just machines that can
detect objects and images but you know
things like this or this or this or if
you are more
um an affairsync line things like this
right the kinds of intelligent machines
that were popular as in science fiction
that capture the imagination maybe
they're quite a ways away but how do we
start taking steps towards this kind of
thing
um
I think deeply enforced learning forms a
significant part of that and I think if
we study it now we might put ourselves
on the path to eventually answer some
pretty fundamental questions
so why should we study deep rainforced
learning today
well
part of the answer is a big end-to-end
trained models seem to work quite well
if we use large data sets and large
models like Transformers we can solve
some pretty impressive problems
and at the same time we have RL
algorithms that we could feasibly
combine with deep neural networks we've
figured out a lot about how to implement
RL algorithms so they can be used to
train these kind of big end-to-end
models
and yet learning based control and truly
open world settings remains on a major
open challenge there are some initial
results including the robotics results I
presented the results in other domains
that show the inkling of the capability
of these systems but a lot of potential
has yet to be realized and I'll talk
about some of that potential in today's
lecture and also over the course of this
uh class
and also discuss how some of these ideas
can maybe bring us closer so it's a very
exciting time I think to study this
topic because in some ways many of the
puzzle pieces are falling into place and
yet major questions remain which could
be questions that you yourselves could
answer in your own future work
but before I get into that I want to
discuss a little bit about the broader
picture of the reinforced learning field
besides the basic problem of maximizing
reward functions what are other problems
that we need to solve to enable real
world sequential decision making because
this course is not just about reward
maximization it's also about a variety
of other problems that crop up and we
study
decision making and control in realistic
data-driven settings and the kinds of
methods that could address it
for example basic reinforcement learning
deals with maximizing Rewards but this
is not the only problem that matters for
sequential decision making we'll cover
more advanced topics like learning
reward functions from examples which is
referred to as inverse reinforcement
learning transferring knowledge between
domains like transfer learning and metal
learning learning to predict and using
prediction to act and so on
here's one question where do rewards
come from if you're playing a video game
it's pretty obvious maybe the reward
function is the score in the video game
you kind of don't have to think about it
very hard but in other settings you do
what if you want to get a robot to pick
up a jug and pour a glass of water
well any child could do this but just
figuring out the reward function is the
water in the glass is itself a complex
perception problem
there's a there's a paper that was
published by some folks at UC Berkeley
on exploration actually about four or
five years ago and had this nice quote
as human agents we are accustomed to
operating with rewards that are so
sparse that we only experience in them
once or twice in a lifetime if at all
what this means is that a lot of the
things that humans do that are very
impressive their War might be so delayed
that it's very difficult to imagine
learning just from that reward signal
for example the reward that you'll
receive for um let's say completing a
PhD degree uh you'll only get that
reward once and you maybe experience
some satisfaction the real outcome might
be what you do afterwards with that
degree and yet you might set yourself on
the path to do that clearly it's not
something that you learn through trial
and error by attempting many many PhD
degrees in the past
this is actually a quote that was posted
on Reddit where the comments are applied
with by writing I paid the author
so we know that there is actually a
structure in the human brain the basal
ganglia which is actually responsible
for the reward signal that the brain
uses for reinforcement I mean this is
actually something that's been studied
quite a lot and it's a non-trivial
structure you can see it you know it
takes up quite a bit of space so clearly
it's doing something sophisticated and
it's not hard to imagine that for
example for a cheetah that it needs to
chase down a gazelle well if the cheetah
learns through trial and error receiving
the reward only when it caught the
gazelle that's a pretty ridiculous image
of a learning system if the cheetah just
runs around on the Savannah randomly
hoping to randomly stumble into a
gazelle then randomly eat it and only
then realize that kitchen gazelle is a
good idea well that cheetah will
probably die of starvation of course
cheetahs don't learn in this way they
might learn from observing other
cheetahs they might learn from their
their parents they might learn from all
sorts of other signals but clearly
they're not learning from rewards
obtained only from eating the meat of
the gazelle at the end of a successful
hunt right so there's a lot that goes on
into these reward signals uh and you
could imagine extracting other more uh
useful forms of supervision you could
learn from demonstrations either by
directly copying The observed Behavior
or even inferring rewards from sort of
behavior by something called inverse
reinforcement learning you can learn
from observing the world learn to
predict what will happen next even if
you're not sure what you're supposed to
be doing and then leverage that
knowledge later once you're more aware
of what your task is you can employ
unsupervised learning on supervised
feature extraction things like that you
can also transfer Knowledge from other
tasks you can even use metal learning
where you learn to adapt more quickly
from your past experience of solving
other tasks and these are all things
that we could try to leverage and these
are all things that we'll actually learn
about in this course
here's an example of imitation learning
this is actually a fairly old example at
this point from about 80 years ago from
some work from Nvidia showing a purely
imitation based method of poor
autonomous driving
now this method tries to directly copy
the actions with the observed human
driver but of course you could do a lot
better you could for example in further
intent and we know this is something
that humans do this is a psychology
study uh here the test subject is the
child on the right hand side now you can
see the child here is not going to try
to imitate what the experimenter is
doing because clearly the experimenter
is not doing something very smart what
the child will do instead is in further
intent and then taking a very different
sequence of actions that is better for
fulfilling their intent rather than
simply copying them this is really the
Hallmark of human imitation when we say
that a person imitates somebody else
they're not literally observing
someone's muscle activations and
Performing the same muscle activations
at some level they're always inferring
something about what that other creature
or person is attempting to do and then
doing it in their own way it might be
very literal where they still carry out
the same motions but figure out the
commands to their muscles that will
create those motions or might be even
more abstract like it is here where they
carry out entirely different actions but
that lead to the seemingly desired okay
inverse enforce learning algorithms can
be actually used with robots this is
again work that's at this point pretty
old it's about eight years old that
shows an inverse reinforcement algorithm
or this robot infers the intent of the
human demonstrator showing this poor
emotion figures out that the point is to
really seek out that yellow cup and to
pour the content of the orange cup into
the yellow cup and once it inferred that
intent then it could perform the task in
a variety of settings
foreign
is a really big part of control
prediction is separate from how we
typically think of model free
reinforcement learning but there's ample
evidence in neuroscience and psychology
the prediction is very important part of
how humans and animals learn about their
world we could imagine predictive models
in a very literal sense where you could
actually predict your future sensory
readings and you can Implement real
world predictive models so here a robot
plays around with objects in its
environment collects some data and then
learns to predict what it will see in
response to different actions so the
different columns here show predicted
future images in response to different
motor commands this is quite a while
back this is seven years ago so you can
see that the predictions here are not a
very high quality but they capture the
gist of what the robot is trying to do
and they can be used to control objects
so you can tell it move this particular
object marked in red to the green
location it'll imagine the movement and
then it will actually actuate the arm to
move the object in that way so
predictive models can allow you to solve
new tasks
you can use this as a very powerful tool
for emergent Behavior you could for
example command the robot to move some
objects and might figure out that it
needs to pick up a tool to move those
two objects together
uh here's another two use example here
it figures out that L-shaped tool can
slide the the blue object and here
there's an emergent tool use scenario
where it figures out to move these two
pieces of trash the uh water bottle
makes for a nice uh improvised tool
and predictive models have really come a
long way so in recent years they've
gotten a lot better with modern advances
in general modeling it is a diffusion
based video prediction model that is
being used to synthesize clips of
driving videos the first three frames
here are real the remaining frames are
actually synthesized and you can see
that the model will actually produce a
realistic camera movement it will
introduce new objects as the car turns
it will um
even um predict the motion of the other
cars with some Reasonable Doubt in these
in these examples by the way the left
video inch pair is the real one the
right one is the synthetical
and here are the same uh model is being
run on robotic videos similar to the
ones that I showed before just so you
can see the contrast from 2017 to 2022
you can see that now the arm is clear
and crisp the objects move in realistic
ways and so forth
there's also a lot of interesting
progress especially in the past year on
leveraging advances in pre-trained
models so when we do reinforcement
learning we typically don't have to do
it from scratch what we could do is we
could use a model pre-train on large
amounts of internet data and then use it
for control this is actually an
imitation learning example it doesn't do
well it actually does direct indication
but it is doing a learning based control
this is the rt2 model which uses a first
a language model that is a pre-trained
on language then a visual language model
that uses that language model to process
internet images for things like question
answering like what is happening in the
images say it's a great donkey walking
down the street so now the model
understands pictures it understands text
and then that model is further
fine-tuned to upload robot actions so
that when it's told what should the
robot do to pick up the chips it'll
output the numerical values for the
actions that'll actually pick up the
ships so now it can bring in knowledge
that it learned from the internet to
perform this task more effectively
here are some examples of the kind of
intelligence tasks that this model can
pass so it can be told to move the
banana to the bottle the robot data has
examples of moving bananas but to
understand what it means to move into
the bottle that's leverage internet data
here it's asked to solve a math problem
by putting the banana on the answer of
the math problem here it's told to put
the strawberry into the correct Bowl to
figure out what correct Bowl means it
needs to recognize the fruits in each of
the bowls and figure out that strawberry
Bowl is in fact the correct one
foreign
here's some more examples pick up an
object that is different from all the
other objects now it knows how to pick
up obvious in the robot data but it
doesn't know what different from all the
others means from that but that has to
leverage internet data and it figures
out that the bar is the different object
because all the other objects are
bottles
you can understand instruction in other
languages even though the robot data is
only annotated in one language and so on
okay so these are some examples of the
kinds of problems that are that we might
study in the context of learning based
decision making besides the 4rl problems
but to conclude this lecture I want to
end on maybe a somewhat more grandiose
point I want to come back to this
question how do we build intelligent
machines and really argue that the basic
building blocks of deep RL might be very
good building blocks for answering this
question
this will force a controversial
statement I don't expect everybody to
agree with me on this this is a big part
of why I'm excited about this topic and
I hope to convey some of that excitement
to you
so imagine they have to build an
intelligent machine something that as
intelligent as a person where would you
start
well in the olden days the way we would
think about this is that maybe we need
to understand the brain and the brain
has a lot of parts so let's understand
what those parts are figure out how each
of them work and then write computer
programs to emulate the behavior of each
of those parts
uh of course our modern understanding of
the brain is more advanced than what it
was in the 19th century but parts of the
brain more closely reflect their actual
function but this is still a very
difficult problem because each of the
parts is very complex and if you we have
to do a bunch of programming to code up
the behavior of each of the parts and do
a bunch more coding to wire them
together we might be at this for a very
long time that might just be a very very
difficult way to implement an
intelligent machine it might actually
take a lot more intelligence on our part
than we actually have
so if we hypothesized that learning
might be the basis of intelligence that
might actually offer us a much easier
way to address this problem
and here's an argument of why learning
might be the basis of intelligence
there are some things that we can all do
like walking so it might be reasonably
argued that maybe those things are sort
of built into our brains somehow
but there are also some things that we
can only learn like driving a car
clearly driving a car is not built into
our brains because cars weren't around
when our brains evolved
and we can learn a huge variety of
things including very difficult things
so therefore our learning mechanisms are
likely powerful enough to do everything
that we associate with intelligence it
may be that in practice we don't
actually use our learning mechanisms for
some things like walking
but we might hypothesize that maybe
they're powerful enough that if we
didn't have those things built in we
could figure it out anyway
that may or may not be true but I think
uh there's a pretty good reason to
believe this might be true
it might still be very convenient to
hard code a few really important bits
but let's not get distracted by that
part
we can further hypothesize that not only
is learning the basis of intelligence
but in fact maybe there's actually a
single learning procedure that underlies
all that we associate with intelligent
Behavior now that's a more radical
statement it basically says that the way
that we learn how to see and the way
that we learn how to talk and learn how
to hear is at some level the same
instead of having an algorithm for every
module I think we have a single flexible
algorithm that placed in the right
context increments all of the modules
everything that we need in the brain
and there are some uh circumstantial
evidence to indicate that this might in
fact be the case for example
um and this these are some slides
borrowed from Android you can build an
electrode array that you can put on your
tongue attach that array to a camera and
learn how to perceive visual process
through your tongue you can take an
animal a ferret you can disconnect the
optic nerve from the visual cortex and
plug it into the auditory cortex and
after a while the ferret will regain
some degree of visual Acuity which means
that its auditory cortex can essentially
learn to process visual settings
so these things kind of indicate that
perhaps there's a degree of generality
or homogeneity to the brain at least for
the neocortex such that it can adapt to
whatever sensory input is provided which
might indicate that there's one
algorithm
and if there is one algorithm what does
this one algebra need to be able to do
well it needs to interpret Rich sensory
inputs and needs to choose complex
actions and to do both of those things
we need large high-capacity models
because that's the only way we know how
to deal with risk sensory inputs and we
need reinforcement learning because
that's the mathematical formulas we use
to take actions
so why deep reinforcement learning well
the Deep part provides us with scalable
learning from large complex data sets
and the reinforced learning gives us the
optimization the ability to take actions
the combination of learning and search
deep is great for learning reinforcement
learning is the way that we do the
search
and in fact there is some evidence in
Neuroscience for both these things
there's evidence that
uh the kinds of representations acquired
by Deep neural networks have some
statistical similarity to
representations that are observed in the
brain that doesn't mean that the brain
works the same way that deep Nets do it
just means that at some level when you
process lots of data and extract
suitable representations they end up
looking similar which could have more to
do with the fact that a large enough
learning machine just pulls out those
patterns in the data because that's what
the data is made of we're going to say
something about deep learning that's I
think a much harder question to answer
but the evidence suggests that some kind
of representational similarity exists
for visual percepts for auditory
features and even for the sense of touch
and the experiment's done done to
ascertain the structure a little bit
creative where the brain signals
indicating the kind of features that in
this case monkeys use for touch are
obtained from recordings from Monkey
neurons the Deep learning experiments
done by actually taking a glove dusted
with
um
white dust you getting a person to touch
objects and then using a deep neural
network to discover patterns in the the
dust patterns on the on the glove so
interesting experiments suggests that
maybe the Cisco properties of features
extracted by sufficiently powerful
learning machines resemble the Futures
in the brain
and there's plenty of evidence in favor
of reinforcement learnings at least one
of the mechanisms underlying decision
making in humans and animals in fact uh
reinforcement actually emerged as a
study of animal intelligence but we know
now from evidence that percepts that
anticipate reward become associated with
similar firing patterns as the reward
itself which is exactly what we would
expect from a temporal difference
learning process uh the basal ganglia
appears to be a kind of reward system
and that model 3rl like adaptation is
often a good fit for experimental data
of animal adaptation
a lot always
but the picture is not complete right so
all of these uh kind of bits of
circumstantial evidence might suggest
that the tools of deep learning and
reinforcement learning might be good
tools for tackling the problem of
intelligence
but the problem is clearly not solved
we have great methods that can learn
from huge amounts of data by using deep
learning we have great optimization
methods for RL we don't yet have amazing
methods that both use data RL has been
made much more scalable in recent years
it can tackle things like real world
robotics problems but the kind of huge
scale language model in general modeling
applications still primarily use
supervised learning so there's still
some algorithmic building blocks that
are necessary and furthermore humans
learn incredibly quickly whereas deep RL
methods typically require large amounts
of data and humans reuse past knowledge
whereas transfer learning URL is still
an open problem it's not always clear
what the reward function should be and
it's not always clear what the role of
prediction should be it seems like these
methods can be very powerful but how do
they fit in with model free methods are
they just different things or can they
be reconciled in some way so all these
question marks I think give us uh ample
space for additional research that we
can do in this area and perhaps if the
tools of deep learning and reinforcement
learning are the right tools for
building enormously powerful artificial
intelligence systems that may be
studying these questions can allow us to
make some Headway on that problem
and ultimately I think that we can get
away from this picture thinking of uh
intelligent systems as a collection of
modules to implement and instead as a
very elegant and simple framework where
we have a general learning algorithm
that can figure out whatever problems is
posed to it in fact this idea is Not By
Any Means new it's not something that
was created in 21st century it's not
even some of those created for deep
learning or even in the age of machine
learning
here's a quote that I think very nicely
exemplifies this perspective instead of
trying to produce a program to simulate
the adult mind why not rather try to
produce one which simulates the child's
If This Were then subjected to an
appropriate course of Education one
would obtain the adult brain who said
this
I'll try